[Music]
this is a very nice surprise ladies and
gentlemen as a result of putting
together this breaking bad episode
we actually got a new sponsor
yeah we picked up a new sponsor with an
exciting new product we are thrilled
here's their ad
why does getting in shape have to be so
complicated
why does workout equipment need to be so
confusing and bulky
well no it doesn't from the producers of
breaking bad comes a revolutionary new
workout system
introducing barrel flex the full body
barrel workout fitness experts agree
rolling a heavy barrel through the hot
new mexico desert is the fastest way to
achieve a sculpted sexy look and now you
can enjoy that same high results low
impact workout at home the barrel flex
targets every major muscle group biceps
triceps triceps monosex and the often
ignored hunch muscles
plus setting up couldn't be easier just
position your barrel flex and fill it
with 10 million dollars in cash any less
and it won't work
then install your rolling desert
backdrop and you're good to go
plus with a few simple adjustments you
can take your barrel flex on the go for
a powerful cardio workout and once
you've mastered the barrel flex try our
full line of breaking bad workout
systems including the pizza tech cardio
x-ray disc and the bike log gangster
choke stretch tech 4000 with adjustable
tension dummy
we promise the barrel flex full body
workout is the last exercise system
you'll ever need just ask one of our
satisfied customers
i use it every day
brian cranston is in no way endorsing
the barrel flex system nor is he
affiliated with it in any way mr
cranston was not actually aware he was
in a commercial for the barrel flex
system and he was simply asked if he
ever uses hand soap get the barrel flex
system now and we guarantee results
within six weeks or we'll apologize
[Music]
order now and receive a free bonus gift
the finger strengthening bell toner
prolact system
[Applause]
that's a good workout